des commémorations qui peut-être vont
sceller la réconciliation entre le
Limousin et l'Alsace c'était en tout cas
le sentiment exprimé par le Premier
ministre Jean-Pierre affarin ce matin
lors des cérémonies que vous avez pu
suivre en direct sur notre antenne parmi
les Alsaciens sur place une délégation
barinoise du Souvenir français et puis
des élus officiellement invités les
marques de considération à leur égard
étai en soi tout un symbole renaultarder
Jérôme
Gosset sur les marches al dédié au 642
victimes d'Adour c'est un instant à la
fois solennel inédit et
historique Adrien Z Philippe Richer et
Fabian Keller ensemble déposent une
gerbe au nom de
l'Alsace ce matin ce fut l'un des gestes
particulièrement salué par un premier
ministre venu s'adresser au
habitsour
pourouvrec
c'est ce que vous avez fait en trouvant
le chemin de la
réconciliation avec vos propres
compatriotes avec les Alsaciens dont je
salue ici les représentants avec votre
propre pays il faut le dire placé
ostensiblement en tête du cortège
officiel la délégation des élus
alsaciens a été reçu avec beaucoup
d'égard un accueil qui va bien au-delà
du simple protocole nous avons senti que
quelque chose se passait entre nous et
les représentants du Limousin et nous
avons pensé que ce moment-là était un
moment historique qui va grandement
faciliter les relations entre nos deux
régionsut dire que nous étions déjà sur
le bon chemin mais les signaux qui ont
été donnés aujourd'hui étaient des
signaux très forts je crois que ça a été
très apprécié a des gens ici qui
derrière nous nous ont dit merci comme
ça moi-même je je reste toute la journée
pour pouvoir largement échanger avec de
nombreux élus leur parler aussi
de l'horreur nazie en Alsace des
incorporés de force et puis entendre
leur immense douleur des des familles
des disparus d'Oradour il y a les
paroles il y a les actes tôt ce matin
Fabienne Keller rencontré pour la
première fois son homologue
d'Oradour je crois que c'est la première
fois que vous venez à aadour absolument
et c'est la raison pour laquelle je suis
d'autant plus heureux de vous y
accueillir le maire de Strasbourg doit
désormais reprendre le travail de
rapprochement entamé par Roland ris et
stoppé depuis 5
je crois que au bout de 60 ans il est
temps qu'il y ait un climat une
d'apaisement entre l'alace et je
CIS nous y nous allons doucement que
j'exliqu
àame promis ce matin Strasbourg
remplacera les statut offertes puis
vandalis il y a quelques années nouveau
gestes d'un rapprochementalsace et
Limousin devront apprendre à développer